so one of the fun things about working
for Wired as I said hey what did you
like at CES so far and I found the thing
and I think it's probably my favorite
this is the neo node end - I saw this
having dinner a couple nights ago next
to this dude he pulls one out starts
talking on it in Swedish and it turns
out it's a Swedish phone it's GSM it's
not currently license the United States
yet but they will have that soon I know
they're in negotiation to try to get it
over here with a major carrier you can
go to neo node calm and check out their
story and see some videos and see it in
action and it's six or seven hundred
dollars unlocked which means that you
can actually put any SIM card in it if
you buy the phone but I would wait till
it comes to America probably at the end
of the second quarter because then the
price will drop when it goes to a
carrier - maybe three or four hundred
bucks but anyway the major cool thing
about this phone is that they've
developed their own technology they have
a series of finger wipes I know that
doesn't sound appealing but it works
pretty awesome so there's a series of
finger wipe shortcuts you got your
contacts an mp3 player plays video
really well it's got a little external
speaker it actually comes in the box
with a mini SD card there's a slot on
the side so there's your memory little
earbuds which are pretty badass as well
the unique thing about it though is that
it's not just a touchscreen it's an
optical touchscreen which means that
there are horizontal and vertical beams
of light on the X and y-axis which track
your finger position so rather than like
the iPhone which is pressure-sensitive
this actually will pinpoint exactly with
light where your finger is so there's
not a lot of miss poking this thing is
way way way awesome if it comes to the
States check it out go to neo node comm
it's the n2 and also you can see they
just have a lot of other really cool
Scandinavian design technology so keep
an eye out for this company I think
they're really gonna make a big splash
you